[Music]
next guest the talented comedian who can
be seen at Cobbs comedy club in San
Francisco March 23rd to the 25th is
something very funny Dana Gould thank
you very much thank you have you ever
dated a goth chick for four or five
months till you realize she was just an
Orthodox Jew they have very similar
costumes
looks are important and I understand
that it's when people take it too far
when plastic surgery becomes habitual
women do it all the time to look younger
and it would make perfect sense if one
of them ever came out looking younger
but they don't they just look the same
no matter who they look like coming in
they come out with that same plastic
surgery face they look like the girl
from the band on the Muppet Show Janice
men do it too you know not as much I did
read an article what one guy was getting
plastic surgery he was in his late 70s
getting plastic surgery in your late 70s
it's kind of like painting your houses
the fire approaches
just died there's no shame in it we're
all on the same conveyor belt I have a
morbid fascination with death it's the
only reason I watched the show storage
wars
come on abandoned storage units I'm just
waiting for that one episode now I'm
gonna see what's behind this pinball
machine it's a bucket of hands nothing
but children's shoes and clown makeup
and you stay in there and say there's a
god but I'm not a cynical person I'm a
very optimistic person and the source of
my optimism individual human achievement
you know and when one person does
something amazing and the example I
always give professor Stephen Hawking
now here is a man who cannot walk who
cannot speak who cannot move
independently and yet he still found a
way to cheat on his wife
[Music]
that is that's the rumor and he got
caught last you think you might get away
with it I'm sure you think you're a very
clever the guy who have figured out how
time started didn't delete his inbox
quickly enough and he is widely
considered the smartest man alive
and yet he's crazy about the ladies his
brain works up here and down there full
throttle all the time I find that
fascinating he's having these very
intellectual conversations with these
other great minds in the vacuum of space
the implosion of a star creates a
negative ion pulse guys guys
two o'clock o'clock either somebody
shoplifting cantaloupe or a genie just
granted my wish is she coming over here
he's the Beatles of scientists if that
represents the most successful version
you can be of a thing then by that
definition the Rolling Stones are the
Beatles of music not counting the
Beatles
John Lennon is the Beatles of the
Beatles but that only works on uplifting
things you know you're never watching a
documentary Adolf Hitler the Beatles of
dictators by all accounts the killing
fields of Cambodia were the Beatles of
human suffering in the 20th the end
thank you very much
[Applause]